Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du, der Merz hat gesagt, dass 4% für die FDP noch 4% zu viel ist.
Also ich fände 3,84% immer noch zu viel.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 513 vom 8. Februar 2025,
und ehrlich gesagt, ich finde ja auch 4% wäre eigentlich und die CDU eigentlich auch zu viel.
Und nicht nur 4% zu viel, sondern 100%. Ja, es ist einfach, naja,
also ich würde sie jetzt, Naja, ich würde generös sein.
Ich würde sie nicht komplett unrepräsentiert lassen.
Wer ist denn auf Platz 1? Merz dann, ne?
Merz ist nirgendwo auf Platz 1. Merz ist einfach nur, ich glaube,
auf der Liste der unbeliebtesten Politiker auf Platz 1. Das ist ja ganz interessant.
Die CDU ist die Partei mit der aktuell höchsten Anzahl Stimmen.
30 Prozent oder so rangieren die ja.
Während die Grünen, die sind ja bei 13 Prozent oder so, die haben aber den beliebtesten
Politiker. Also der Kanzlerkandidat der Grünen ist der beliebteste unter den
Kanzlerkandidaten aktuell.
Ja, hilft ja aber meistens nichts.
Nee.
Machen wir uns da keine Illusionen. Wir werden schon irgendwie mit einem störenden,
großen Anteil an CDU-Wahlstimmen rumschlagen müssen, glaube ich. Wann ist diese Wahl?
23. Februar.
15 Tagen sozusagen.
Krass, ist das echt schon so bald, ne?
Ja.
Ja, und schade.
Naja, Tim, hast du denn mitbekommen, dass der Faschofritz, wie ich ihn nenne,
der Faschofritz, Fisch frische Faschos, Fisch frische Faschos, Fisch frische Faschos.
Ja. Habe ich irgendwie am Rande mitbekommen.
Seit 2018 hat die CDU einen Unvereinbarkeitsbeschluss, der jede Zusammenarbeit
mit der AfD ausschließt.
Auch Friedrich Merz ist ja auch angetreten, also ist ja auch verständlich,
dass er die AfD zu seinem Primärfeind oder Primärgegner gemacht hat und gesagt hat,
ich hole quasi diese verlorenen Stimmen der CDU,
die da zu der AfD gegangen sind, die hole ich zurück.
Und das ist ja, also ich meine, wo soll ja auch sonst herkommen,
außer jetzt von der Sarah Wagenknecht oder so,
es werden jetzt eher nicht so
viele Leute von den Grünen zur AfD gewandert sein oder von der SPD auch,
aber sicherlich schaden die FDP-Wählerinnen primär dem CDU-CSU-Ergebnis.
Und entsprechend hat er ja sehr viel rumgetönt, das war irgendwie keine Zusammenarbeit
mit denen und wenn irgendeiner in seiner Partei mit der AfD stimmt,
fliegt er raus und so weiter und so fort.
Und dann hatten wir ja jetzt diesen Vorfall in Aschaffenburg,
wo ein Mensch, ich glaube mit einem Messer ein Kind angegriffen hat.
Und das lag natürlich, das kann ja nur daran gelegen haben, dass der Mensch
aus einem anderen Land kam. Das hat ja nichts damit zu tun, dass der psychische
Probleme hatte oder so, sondern es war ja einfach nur seine Herkunft.
Und deswegen hat Fritze Merz sich überlegt, ja pass auf, da müssen wir doch
jetzt mal endlich was mit dieser Migration machen, weil offensichtlich liegt das ja daran.
Kann ja an nichts anderem liegen. Kann auch nicht daran liegen,
wie Menschen, die in dieses Land kommen, hier mit unterbehandelt und betreut werden.
Nein, nein, nein, das liegt an deren Herkunft.
Und dann hat er gesagt, er bringt jetzt einen Entwurf ein, oder er bringt zwei
Anträge in den Bundestag ein.
Der erste war im Prinzip so ein Beschluss, nicht ein Gesetzesentwurf,
sondern einfach so quasi eine Beschlussfassung.
Der Bundestag möge beschließen.
Wir finden folgendes. Das zweite war dann auch tatsächlich, der hätte Gesetzescharakter
gehabt, da bleiben wir mal bei dem ersten.
Und dann wurde er quasi gefragt, wie er sich das denn jetzt vorstellt.
Da hat er gesagt, das ist jetzt mein Antrag und den bringe ich ein.
Ob er denn Lust hätte, den noch mit irgendjemandem zu diskutieren?
Und dann hat er gesagt, nee, mache ich nicht, der wird nicht diskutiert,
der wird so eingereicht.
Und dann wurde gesagt, naja, was machst du denn, wenn jetzt die SPD und die
Grünen dagegen stimmen und die AfD mit deiner Partei dafür?
Und da hat er sinngemäß gesagt, ja, das ist mir völlig egal,
wer dafür zustimmt und wörtlich gesagt, was in der Sache richtig ist,
wird nicht falsch, wenn die Falschen zustimmen.
Und das ist ja, also grundsätzlich könnte man das ja sogar so sehen, ja,
allerdings ausgerechnet, so ausgerechnet ein Migrationsthema und ausgerechnet
eines, wo er ja selber sagt, mit den anderen diskutiere ich da nicht drüber,
das wird so gemacht oder nicht, weil es ja auch klar ist,
dass die da nicht zustimmen, ja.
Und wo auch, wenn er quasi sich da keine Kompromiss- oder Diskussionsbereitschaft zeigt.
Und wenn er da aussagt, eben 100% AfD-Scheiße reinschreibt, ist ja auch völlig
vorhersehbar, dass die da mitstimmen.
Von dem, was man so aus den gut unterrichteten Kreisen hört,
war diese Äußerung von Friedrich Merz nicht geplant oder abgesprochen.
Also es stand jetzt nicht im Skript seiner Rede. So, das scheint also eher,
keine Ahnung, scheint jemand eine Frage gestellt zu haben, so weit hatte der
noch nicht gedacht und dann hat er halt irgendeine scheiß Antwort geliefert
und dann sah er sich dann halt da mit dem Problem sitzen. Worum ging es?
Er wollte, also diese Beschlussvorlage da, das soll ein Fünf-Punkte-Plan sein,
dauerhafte Grenzkontrollen an allen deutschen Grenzen.
Konsequente Zurückweisung aller Versuche,
Und irreguläre Einreise, auch von Personen mit Schutz gesucht.
Das heißt, jemand, und das komme ich gleich zu,
also damit ein Einreiseverbot für Personen ohne gültige Einreisedokumente und
ausreisepflichtige Personen sollen sofort inhaftiert werden und dafür müssen
wir dann jetzt auch Platz schaffen,
damit wir die alle einknasten können, bis wir die abschieben.
Und dann natürlich Aufenthaltsrecht für Straftäter und Gefährder verschärfen
und so weiter, inklusive unbefristeter Ausreisearrest.
Nun, also wie gesagt, er hat in dem Problem ausschließlich eines gesehen,
was sich aus der Herkunft des Menschen speist.
Er hat dann auch noch irgendwie im Bundestag später von täglichen Massenvergewaltigungen
durch Migranten gesprochen.
Also völlig, der Typ hat völlig jedes Maß verloren.
Und naja, was ist passiert? Klar, die Diskussion im Bundestag war hitzig.
SPD und Grüne haben selbstverständlich dagegen gestimmt.
CDU und FDP für diesen Vorschlag von Merz. und natürlich auch die AfD.
Nicht zu vergessen sind die Leute vom BSW, die durch ihre Enthaltung,
wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, das Ding genauso ermöglicht haben.
Ich glaube, das waren genug, wenn die dagegen gestimmt hätten, wäre es auch gekippt.
Richtig.
Also eine Shitshow Sondergleichen.
Die einzige Partei, wie kann der so blöd sein? Wie kann er so doof sein?
Und zu allem Überfluss ...
Hat die CDU dadurch jetzt noch nicht mal den Schaden genommen,
den sie verdient hätte, aber natürlich hat die AfD, die AfD-Leute haben irgendwie
Party und Selfies gemacht, nachdem die Abstimmung durch war.
Also ein absolutes Geschenk an die AfD, den gesamten Wahlkampf zweieinhalb,
drei Wochen vor der Wahl auf ein Migrationsthema zu zerren.
Das wird der AfD einfach richtig nochmal Power geben.
Also es ist unglaublich. Natürlich riesige Demonstrationen aller Orten.
Und dann geht er natürlich hin und er wird sofort gehetzt gegen,
ja, die haben aber hier den Straßenverkehr, ging er auf einmal nicht mehr.
Und das unterstellt er den Demonstrierenden
Gewalt oder so, dass sie ihr Demonstrationsrecht missbrauchen würden.
Das fand ich mal eine ganz interessante Perspektive, Weil darunter waren natürlich
relativ viele CDU-Wählerinnen auch, die sagen, ja, also irgendwie alles noch so, sagen wir mal,
Ausländerfeindlichkeiten mit einem Rest-Humanismus vertreten.
Und aus guten Gründen sich quasi mit für sich guten Gründen noch vor der AfD zurückschrecken.
Also du meinst, die jetzt Teil der Demonstranten waren?
Genau, ja, ich konnte so schöne Interviews lesen von Leuten,
die so irgendwelche Ende 50,
beide die gleiche Anorak an, das erste Mal auf einer Demonstration und dann
werden sie direkt verunglimpft als Missbrauch des Demonstrationsrechts, also der März wirklich.
Also Missbrauch von Leuten, die das erste Mal überhaupt Gebrauch davon gemacht haben sozusagen.
Ja, ja, genau. Direkt falsch gemacht.
Das geht es ja nur nicht hier als CDU-Wähler. Hat man sowas nicht zu machen.
Und dann wird darüber diskutiert, war das jetzt ein Fall der Brandmauer,
dass eben demokratische Parteien,
nicht mit den Faschisten stimmen,
Und da ist natürlich ein wichtiger Aspekt, den muss man dabei nochmal betonen,
weil wenn jetzt die geneigte Leserin sucht, natürlich haben die schon öfter zusammengestimmt.
Also es gab schon immer wieder auch mal ein Stimmverhalten der CDU und der AfD.
Das Entscheidende ist, dass das hier mehrheitsverschaffend war.
Ob die AfD mitstimmt oder nicht, ist so lange egal den demokratischen Parteien
aus gutem Grund, bis es mehrheitsentscheidend ist.
Weil dann gibst du ja quasi dieser Fraktion die Entscheidungsmacht.
Und aus diesem Grund war es bisher sinnvolle Gepflogenheit, sich unter den Demokraten zu einigen,
um genau den Faschisten nicht diese Erfolge zu geben oder diesen Erfolg zu geben, den sie jetzt feiern.
Ja, ich meine dieses Migrationspapier ist natürlich auch wirklich haarsträubend.
Nehmen wir so ein klassisches Beispiel für, wir beschließen jetzt mal irgendetwas,
was halt in Teilen, wenn ich das richtig sehe, auch gesetzwidrig ist.
Also dauerhafte Grenzkontrollen sind, glaube ich,
europäisch überhaupt nicht durchführbar, weil es sozusagen gibt ja eine Vereinbarung
Schengen, dass es sozusagen immer nur zeitlich befristet sein darf,
wenn irgendwas ganz offensichtliches passiert ist. was weiß ich,
Terrorgefahr, blablabla.
Gab es ja ein paar Mal, als wir da die Anschläge in Frankreich hatten, etc.
Andere Dinge und der Rest ist halt auch einfach alles nur so Schaulaufen.
Wir tun mal was und ich weiß nicht, dass die Bundespolizei Leute arretieren
darf, ist glaube ich derzeit rechtlich auch noch gar nicht vorgesehen, oder? Täusche ich mich.
Ich habe mir das mal zusammen suchen lassen. Also die Grenzkontrollen dauerhaft
und das Zurückweisen von Asylsuchenden bei Schutzanspruch würden dem Schengener
Grenzkodex und der Dublin-III-Verordnung widersprechen.
Außerdem,
gibt es eben den freien Grenzübertritt ohne Personenkontrollen durch Artikel 1777 Absatz 1,
A, E, U, V. Habe ich den Tag, ich weiß nicht genau, für die allgemeine EU-Verordnung oder sowas.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist. Sekunde, das müssen wir,
hätte ich genauer.
Der Vertrag über die Arbeitsweise der Europäischen Union.
Ah ja, der Vertrag über die Arbeitsweise der Europäischen Union.
Die Union entwickelt eine Politik, mit der sichergestellt werden soll,
dass Personen unabhängig von ihrer Staatsangehörigkeit beim Überschreiten der
Binnengrenzen nicht kontrolliert werden. Ja, richtig.
Dann natürlich nationales Recht und Grundrecht, die geplante Inhaftierung ausreisepflichtiger
Personen ohne zeitliche Begrenzung. Das sind immer sehr schöne.
Es betrifft natürlich Artikel 2 Absatz 2 Grundgesetz und dann europäische Vorgaben
wie die Rückführungsrichtlinie.
Es ist außerdem, wird das noch so ein Catch-22, weil du kannst ja auch nicht
im Ausland Asyl beantragen.
Und de facto, wenn du sagst, naja, du kannst Asyl nur hier beantragen,
aber ohne gültige Papiere kommst du hier nicht rein, dann setzt du quasi das Asylrecht aus.
Dann darfst du eben auch nach der Zusammenfassung der Arbeitsweise der Europäischen
Union nur nationale Abweichungen machen bei einer Gefährdungslage,
bei einer besonderen Gefährdungslage und da wird der Urteil der Europäische
Gerichtshof auch ganz gerne mal gegen dich.
Und du musst das Ganze natürlich auch irgendwie noch praktisch umsetzen,
was ja auch völliger Unsinn ist, wenn du sagst, wir bauen jetzt hier neue Haftplätze
und kontrollieren die kompletten Außengrenzen Deutschlands. Ich weiß nicht,
wie viele Nachbarländer Deutschland hat.
Mehr als ich dachte. Sieben oder 13 oder sowas?
Zählen wir nochmal durch.
Gucken wir mal.
Dänemark, Polen.
Tschechien, Österreich, Schweiz auch, Frankreich, Belgien, Luxemburg, Niederlande.
Niederlande. Neun?
Neun.
Mal gucken, welche Länder wir jetzt vergessen haben.
Bayern.
Ich glaube es waren, ne neun, du hast recht, du hast ja alle richtig,
du hast ja alle vollständig durch.
Geografie kann ich.
Das stimmt, ich nicht. Geografie war ich nicht gut drin.
Aber ich habe ja gesagt, irgendwas zwischen sieben und dreizehn,
aber damit kriegst du halt auch nur eine Drei in der Geografie.
Genau, also dann irgendwie an all diesen Grenzen, Kontrollen und so weiter.
Und dann natürlich Personen- und Warenverkehr.
Auch eine geile Idee, wenn da demnächst jetzt die ganzen LKWs und so weiter
stehen würden und kontrolliert werden würden.
Also alles nicht besonders gut durchdacht, eine relativ unsinnige Idee,
die da vorgetragen wurde.
Jetzt kommt noch hinzu, das ganze Ding, wie gesagt, fernab einer Realisierungsmöglichkeit,
kein Gesetzesvorschlag, einfach nur irgendein Scheißtext. Also er hätte es auch
einfach sein lassen können.
Er hatte quasi jetzt diesen Brandmauerfall und den Erfolg der AfD hat er denen
geschenkt für nichts und wieder nichts.
Da ist jetzt nicht irgendetwas bei entstanden passiert, irgendetwas geändert
worden, dass man sagen könnte, ja Mensch.
Das war jetzt dann doch notwendig und da hättest du eine Veränderung in der
Bundesrepublik herbeigeführt, die irgendwie vielleicht in deinem politischen
Sinne sein könnte oder so. Das gibt es alles nicht.
Das ist einfach nur komplett für nichts und wieder nichts gewesen und offenbar
von dem, was man so hört, aus einer Laune heraus, aus einem Impuls.
Und das ist natürlich wirklich bedenklich, wenn jemand, der sich anschickt,
das Amt der Bundeskanzlerin in diesem Land zu bekleiden zu wollen,
wenn dem so etwas passiert und man sich quasi sorgen muss um dessen Urteilsvermögen.
In einer solchen Situation, wenn er einem erklärten politischen Gegner einen
derartigen Überraschungserfolg für nichts und wieder nichts auf dem Silbertablett serviert.
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, die AfD-Fraktion.
Es gibt weiterhin sehr genaue Beobachtungen dieser Partei.
Einzelne Landesverbände sind gesichert rechtsextrem.
Die gesamte Partei ist ein Beobachtungsfall. Und es gibt dieses AfD-Gutachten von 2021,
was die ganzen verfassungsfeindlichen Positionierungen und Strömungen der AfD zusammengefasst hat.
Und es gibt natürlich eine weitere, seitdem, seit 2021, weiter durchgeführte
Arbeit des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz, das ein Gutachten in Aussicht gestellt hatte.
Und das erwartete Ergebnis dieses Gutachten ist, dass die Partei hochstuft vom
Verdachtsfall zum gesichert Rechtsextremen oder wie auch immer,
ich kenne mich da nicht genau aus,
was wieder die genauen Stufen sind.
Aber sicherlich, wir werden sie jetzt nicht runterstufen. Wir haben mindestens
die Einstufung beibehalten.
Potenziell war die Erwartung, dass sie eine Hochstufung vornehmen.
Und wir wissen auch seit mindestens über einem Jahr, dass Stimmen laut sind,
die ein Verbotsverfahren machen.
Gegen diese Partei fordern.
Natürlich tun sie dies auch in der Hoffnung, dass die Partei auch verboten wird.
Aber vor allem auch in der Erwartung, dass dann eine genaue Prüfung dieser Partei stattfindet.
Und das ist jetzt leider sehr ungünstig, dass ja das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz gesagt hat, naja,
wir dürfen ja quasi nicht auf Wahlergebnisse einwirken und aus diesem Grund
werden wir unseren aktuellen Stand zur AfD nicht mehr vor der Wahl veröffentlichen,
weil es könnte ja dann sein,
dass das einen Einfluss auf die Wahl ausübt.
Also beispielsweise, angenommen das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz für die
AfD nicht hochstufen, dass dann
Leute sagen, ach ja cool, ist nicht hochgestuft, kann man doch wählen.
Ich traue ja bei meinem Wahlverhalten immer noch mal, lese ich vorher noch mal,
Stiftung Verfassungstest, Testurteil sehr gut oder nicht, ob das auch wirklich,
mir müsste ja jemand noch erklären,
ob die Bestrebungen einer Partei verfassungswidrig sind oder nicht.
Oder es könnte natürlich auch sein, dass eine Hochstufung dazu führt,
dass Leute sagen, ach so, die AfD, das sind Verfassungsfeinde,
dann wähle ich die mal lieber nicht.
Gut, dass mir das nochmal jetzt hier das unabhängige Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz erläutert hat.
Also ich glaube, dass es relativ unsinnig ist, diese Überlegung,
aber okay, wird nicht mehr, werden wir nicht mehr bekommen und entsprechend
wäre natürlich ein solches Gutachten, was da.
Hoffentlich angestellt wird und eine Begründung einer solchen Hochstufung durchaus
relevant für ein Verbot der Partei.
Verbotsantrag selber, oder der Antrag auf die Eröffnung eines Verbotverfahrens
ist ebenfalls gescheitert.
Und es haben sich nun, weil der Bundestag nicht aus dem Kniff kommt,
die Bundesregierung nicht aus dem Kniff kommt, haben sich nun ein paar außerparlamentarische
Gruppen zusammengetan,
um eine Materialsammlung zu generieren.
Also quasi zu sagen, naja, wenn der Verfassungsschutz seine Arbeit nicht öffentlich macht.
Die eben darin bestehen könnte, das Material, das ein Verbotsverfahren bräuchte,
auch zu liefern, dann machen wir es eben selber.
Und haben jetzt quasi eine Spendenkampagne und entsprechende Infrastruktur aufgebaut,
um eine derartige Untersuchung eben öffentlich anzustellen.
Ich glaube, die wollen irgendwie 850.000 Euro sammeln.
Das ist natürlich relativ sportlich. Gutes Sümmchen.
Die GFF ist dabei, Campact und fragt den Staat.
Und der Blog Volksverpetzer. Die sind,
treiben diesen Gedanken voran. Ein größerer Teil der Kohle ist,
glaube ich, eh schon jetzt zusammen.
Cool.
Es ist ein bisschen, also dieser ungelenke Umgang mit,
Der demokratischen Parteien, aber auch der Institutionen, die sich die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland zum Schutz ihrer Demokratie mal aufgebaut hat,
der ist schon wirklich ein bisschen beängstigend oder ein bisschen lame.
Und das erinnert mich auch an das nächste Thema, über das wir sprechen wollen.
Vorher müssen wir aber noch kurz die Geschichte zu Ende erzählen.
Zwei Tage nach dieser Abstimmung wurde dann ein tatsächlicher Gesetzesentwurf
eingebracht von der CDU.
Und in dem sollten quasi tatsächlich konkrete Maßnahmen stattfinden.
Schnellerer Entzug des Aufenthaltstitels und mehr Befugnisse für Sicherheitsbehörden.
Und das war das sogenannte Zustrombegrenzungsgesetz.
Geiler Name.
Ja.
Das ist dann gescheitert. Erfreulicherweise.
Und das liegt, glaube ich, wenn ich das richtig erinnere, daran,
dass ein paar FDPler und auch ein paar Christen der Abstimmung ferngeblieben sind.
Oder auch dagegen gestimmt haben.
Oder auch dagegen gestimmt haben. Ja klar, es gab einzelne Abweichler und das
hatte dann den Merz zu deinem eingangsgebrachten Zitat gegen die FDP gebracht.
Auch das, also ganz ehrlich, der Mann hat wirklich mit einer derartigen Impulsivität,
kannst du doch nicht die Geschicke eines Landes lenken.
Also ich meine, es ist relativ klar,
dass die FDP im Zweifelsfall der Wunschkoalitionspartner ist für die CDU.
Der FDP, dem Lindner hat er ja zu verdanken, dass er jetzt überhaupt früher Kanzler wird.
Und dann jetzt greift er dir an. Also FDP ist natürlich jetzt auch irgendwie
so ein bisschen so, ne, boah, Alter, wir haben dich auch gefallen.
Aber es ist ja auch klar, warum er das macht. Das hat ja was mit der Wahlrechtsänderung,
dem geänderten Wahlgesetz zu tun.
Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat ja angemahnt, dass diese Praxis der Überhangmandate,
diese Verteilung, dass Parteien sozusagen überproportional dann vertreten sind,
beziehungsweise der Bundestag entsprechend aufgebläht wird, dass das so nicht mehr bleiben kann.
Und dann gab es ja jetzt in der letzten Legislaturperiode nach langem Hin und
Her auch ein neues Wahlverfahren.
Und jetzt ist es halt so, dass dieses Geschäft der Leihstimmen,
was die CDU mit der FDP ja oft gemacht hat, so nach dem Motto,
ja, da könnt ihr ruhig mal ein paar Zweitstimmen irgendwie abwerfen,
das schadet uns gar nichts.
Das sieht halt jetzt ganz anders aus das heißt jetzt würde sich sozusagen die
CDU tatsächlich da ins eigene Fleisch schneiden weil vorher haben sie halt durch
ihre gewonnenen Wahlkreise eh schon so viel,
angesammelt, dass sie dann eben auf ein paar Zweitstimmen auch durchaus verzichten können,
aber jetzt weil sie die Direktmandate hatten genau, weil sie die Direktmandate
hatten Ich kann die mathematische Herleitung gerade nicht komplett wiedergeben,
aber das ist halt einer der Gründe,
warum die jetzt da so zickig sind, weil jetzt eben Zweitstimmenverluste der
CDU entsprechend schaden würden.
Also es kann halt durchaus sein, dass halt Leute, die Wahlkreis gewonnen haben,
dann nicht im Bundestag vertreten sind, wenn ich das richtig verstehe.
So habe ich das auch verstanden, diese Wahlrechtsänderung. Und natürlich warnt
er außerdem davor, wenn er sagt, die hat vier Prozent.
Ja, die vier Prozent sind schon mal im Orkos.
Also wenn sie unter fünf kommen, dann ist es ja tatsächlich so,
diese Stimme hat auf jeden Fall weniger Impact als eine,
oder diese Bevölkerungsgruppe hat dann eben überhaupt keine Vertretung im Bundestag.
Fände ich jetzt auch nicht schlimm, aber es ist wirklich eine Shitshow und man fragt sich,
man fühlt sich daran erinnert, weißt du, so, dass dann...
Also eine Zeit lang wunderst du dich und sagst, wie schafft denn die AfD das
mit so einem Stuss, mit so einem Stuss, den die reden.
Und die haben ja auch zu nichts, was in diesem Land diskutiert wird als Problem.
Irgendeinen inhaltlichen Vorschlag, der,
überzeugen würde. Das wäre, also man kann ja sagen, das ist jetzt hier was weiß
ich, das eine ist ein Problem, das andere ist keins oder so,
aber wir reißen jetzt die Windräder ab oder sowas. Das ist ja einfach nur bescheuert.
Also das ist ja richtig, richtig einfach auch nur dummes Zeug.
Und da fragt man sich ja, wie schafft es denn eine Partei.
Mit derartigen Positionierungen überhaupt so einen signifikanten Supporteranteil zu bekommen.
Und wenn man sich dann anschaut, wie die demokratischen Parteien sich in letzter Zeit verhalten,
naja, auf jeden Fall nicht besonders schlau.
Machen wir uns nichts vor. Most people don't care. Most people don't get it.
Also die meisten Leute, denen ist einfach die Welt zu kompliziert,
denen ist die Wahl zu kompliziert, denen ist Politik zu kompliziert und die
denken nicht von der Tapete bis zur Wand.
Das ist alles am Ende Emotionen. und wir haben uns oft schon darüber beschwert
wie Populisten auftreten, egal ob sie jetzt bei der CDU,
bei der FDP beim BSW wo auch immer schon seit Jahrzehnten es gibt dieses Element
immer und es hat auch immer funktioniert und ich würde noch nicht mal ausschließen
wollen dass Merz mit seiner ganzen Tirade am Ende durchaus noch nicht mal dafür groß bestraft wird.
Ja, leider sieht es genau danach gerade aus.
Ja, so läuft der Hase.
Wir haben mittlerweile eine vollkommen Faktenfremdheit in der Gesellschaft entwickelt,
die halt einfach über die Gesellschaftsmedien noch verstärkt wird.
Und am Ende ist alles nur noch gefühlt und Leute haben relativ wenig Aufwand
damit, sich eine beliebige Positionierung schön zu reden,
sich überhaupt nicht mit der Realität auseinanderzusetzen.
Hauptsache es gibt einen Feind und Hauptsache es sind die anderen.
Die anderen sind schuld und jeder, der dieses Mantra von die anderen sind schuld,
ausreichend befördert, das passt dann schon mal und da wird gefeiert und angefeuert,
als wäre man jetzt hier irgendwie in der Kneipe beim Dart spielen und es ist sehr schwierig,
dagegen vorzukommen,
also dagegen anzugehen, Da in irgendeiner Form eine Position zu vertreten,
die halt auf der einen Seite diese Leute anspricht, aber auf der anderen Seite auch….
Noch vernünftig ist.
Vernünftig ist, ja, also ich meine, du siehst das ja immer bei den Grünen.
So der Habeck, der hat ja durchaus auch so eine Art, intellektuell aufzutreten,
weil er intellektuell ist. weil er halt irgendwie auch einer der wenigen ist
in der gesamten Politik, die den Eindruck machen, dass ihn auch,
sagen wir mal, die Sache irgendwie als solche interessiert.
Ja, also der versteht alles.
Der versteht die internationalen und die nationalen politischen Zusammenhänge
und auch die wirtschaftlichen Zusammenhänge etc.
Wenn er aber jetzt anfängt, auch eine Sprache zu entwickeln,
mit der er auch Leute adressiert, die sich jetzt nicht durch so eine logische
Herleitung von Politik überzeugen werden.
Beeindruckend.
Dann schreit ja auch sofort das eigene Lager auf, im großen Schmerz,
weil irgendein Wort benutzt wurde oder irgendein Wort nicht benutzt wurde.
Und da bist du immer hin und her gerissen, weil du musst ja immer alles richtig machen.
Jedes Wort muss ja immer richtig sein, aber einfach mal so draufhauen geht nicht.
Wäre aber wahrscheinlich ganz sinnvoll, auch wenn es, sagen wir mal,
so einer intellektuellen Minderheit immer missbehagt.
Ja, wir hätten sowas halt ganz gerne, so vollintellektuelle,
gemäßigte, milde Menschen, die irgendwie allen zuhören und dann sinnvolle Entscheidungen
fällen und dann passt das schon.
Da sind wir irgendwie gerade nicht so richtig in der Zeit drin.
Das funktioniert irgendwie nirgendwo so richtig.
Die einzigen Länder, wo das noch so halbwegs klappt, sind halt Länder,
in denen die Gesellschaft noch sehr nah beieinander ist.
Das sind halt, und damit meine ich, nah beieinander, wirtschaftlich nah beieinander,
also wo du nicht so starke Unterschiede hast, wo alle irgendwie von dem System profitieren.
Das ist nicht so in Deutschland und auch in vielen anderen Stellen Europas nicht.
Und wo eine gewisse Sicherheit herrscht. Sagen wir mal sowas wie Norwegen.
Oder Luxemburg oder so. Also so Länder, in denen es halt auch wirklich wirtschaftlich sehr gut geht.
Schon in Schweden siehst du
ja in den letzten Jahren gibt es auch eine ganze Menge Stress und Ärger.
Und ja, jetzt haben wir einfach sehr lange sehr aus diesem Plus der Jahrzehnte
und der Friedensdividende uns ernährt und uns sozusagen auch durchgehend toll
gefunden und in den letzten zwei,
drei Jahrzehnten auch komplett auf Zukunftsentwicklung und Realitätsaspekte verzichtet.
Wir haben halt also eine Politik geduldet, die einfach überhaupt nicht bereit
war, dieses Land in irgendeiner Form zukunftsfähig zu machen.
Also weder energietechnisch, klimatechnisch, internettechnisch.
Sozialpolitisch, Wohnungsbau, es ist ja alles irgendwie vom Weg abgekommen.
Und dazu jetzt eben auch noch obendrauf außenpolitisch, sicherheitspolitisch.
Also alles ist verrostet und überall tritt das Wasser aus.
Und jetzt hast du halt einfach auch so eine große Zahl an Menschen,
die einfach unzufrieden sind mit dem, wie sich das entwickelt hat.
Weil für sie dieser Anteil an dieser Gesellschaft nicht da ist.
Und das ist der Nährboden, auf dem halt Faschismus und Populismus ganz wunderbar
funktioniert. Und das ist halt jetzt ein echtes, großes Problem.
Und dann kann man jetzt mit so elitärer, das muss aber alles anders sein,
Logik halt nicht mehr so richtig durchkommen, weil die Leute das nicht mehr
unterscheiden können. Die denken halt einfach so.
Letztlich ist es ja auch in den USA genauso. Natürlich ist das alles falsch, wohin das läuft,
nur sollten wir uns nicht so groß drüber wundern, sondern eher ein bisschen
ärgern darüber, dass die Politik es auf der einen Seite vermisst hat,
da entsprechend mehr in die Zukunft zu denken, aber andererseits muss man sich
auch selber dafür bestrafen, dass man dieser Politik nicht schon sehr viel früher
aufgezeigt hat, dass es so nicht geht.
Aber das Verständnis war halt einfach nicht da.
Also ich habe kein einziges Mal Angela Merkel gewählt.
Ich auch nicht.
Angela Merkel hat sich zu dieser Friedrich-März-Nummer geäußert.
Es gibt eine Webseite, Bürobundeskanzlerin ad oder sowas, da hat sie gesagt,
wie unglaublich besonnen Friedrich Merzloff hat, der selber sagte, jetzt Achtung,
in der Phase zwischen dem Misstrauensvotum gegen Scholz und dem,
dass die Neuwahlen stattfinden in dieser Zeit, muss aufgepasst werden,
dass hier nicht die AfD dieses Vakuum füllt.
Und das geht dadurch, dass man die weiter, dass alle Demokraten,
das hat er spezifisch selber gesagt und er hat das zwei Wochen später mit dem
Arsch eingerissen und das hat Merkel, hat ihn dann nochmal ausführlich gelobt
dafür, was er damals gesagt hat und ihn getadelt dafür,
das ist also auch natürlich ein irrer Vorgang.
Und dann hat man natürlich, feiert man dann Merkel, und die wird ja auch inzwischen
romantisiert, war meine Güte, da war noch eine Frau, die hatte irgendwie,
die hatte irgendwie, ja, die hatte was auf dem Kasten oder so,
und bei der war, unter der war alles ruhig, ja.
Ja, klar, weil sie diese ganzen Probleme, die unsere Gesellschaft jetzt wirklich
nicht mehr ignorieren kann, schön die ganze Zeit weggerautet hat von sich. Und das,
weil da auch teilweise so, ja wir wünschen uns Merkel zurück.
So, nee, ich glaube nicht, dass wir uns die zurückwünschen.
Ich könnte mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass sie noch sehr viel besser Angriffsfläche
für die AfD bieten würde inzwischen, als es Olaf Scholz getan hat.
Oder Friedrich Merz bietet ja keine Angriffsfläche, sondern,
was ist das denn dann, Geschenk, Fläche, der bietet einfach nur Fläche, der gibt den Raum.
Friedrich Merz, naja. Gut,
schauen wir uns an in den USA und ich finde es sehr, sehr wichtig,
den Aspekt, den du da gerade benannt hattest, dass das, was in den Gesellschaften
den Frieden schafft oder aufrechterhält,
ist diese Ausgeglichenheit, das mit dem Nah beieinander hast du das genannt, Dass die Menschen...
Also und ich bin mir ganz sicher, dass das eben auch was ökonomisches ist,
dass die Gesellschaft hier zum Beispiel noch so ein Wohlstandsversprechen macht,
was irgendwie glaubhaft ist.
Oder dass du eine Geschichte des sozialen Aufstiegs und der Eigenverantwortung,
an die ja in Deutschland viel erzählt wird, dass die irgendwie noch glaubhaft ist.
Und diese ganze liberale soziale Marktwirtschaft, in der wir uns hier aufhalten, erzählt dir ja.
Wenn du arm bist, dann bist du arm, weil du nichts leistest.
Und wenn du und du müsstest, du musst nur in der Schule aufpassen und gute Noten
schreiben und dann kriegst du einen guten Job und eine gute Bezahlung und so weiter und so fort.
Und wenn du arbeitslos bist, dann liegt das daran, dass du faul bist und nicht
daran, dass du was weiß ich, dass du Kraftfahrer gelernt hast,
die man halt einfach bald nicht mehr braucht.
Und sich keine Sau darum gekümmert hat, was die jetzt machen sollen,
wenn man sie dann bald nicht mehr braucht.
Oder weil du im Bergwerk gearbeitet hast und man irgendwann gesagt hat,
die Kohle holen wir uns jetzt woanders her und dann werden halt massenhaft Leute
entlassen und dann wird gesagt,
ja hier, du hättest mal was anderes gemacht.
Aber kann auf jeden Fall nicht daran liegen, dass diese Gesellschaft dir ein
Versprechen gemacht hat, was sie dann nicht gehalten hat.
Und vor allem, dass diese Gesellschaft das Versprechen an deine Kinder erst recht nicht hält.
Sozialer Aufstieg, wie nennt man das, diese Durchlässigkeit,
das heißt so, dass also Menschen aus,
irgendwie einkommensschwachen Schichten.
Irgendwie aufsteigen in einkommensstarke
Schichten. Das ist im weit davon entfernten Regelfall zu sein.
Wenn du das Gehalt oder das Haushaltseinkommen von jemandem prognostizieren
willst, nimmst du einfach das der Eltern, fertig.
Und der Rest ist dann irgendwo ein kleiner, das ist dann ein Fehler.
Da hat es irgendwann mal einer geschafft, aus seiner Schicht auszubrechen oder
aus seiner Schicht abzurutschen.
Aber das sind dann, das sind ja Sonderfälle, das sind ja ganz absolute Einzelfälle,
deswegen werden dir ja auch so viel erzählt.
Und das ist natürlich, glaube ich, in den USA ist dieser Effekt schon sehr,
sehr viel stärker und damit kann man sich wahrscheinlich auch erklären,
was die sich jetzt da gewählt haben.
Und da kann man natürlich mal sehr genau hinschauen, wie da das Anti-Establishment
die reichsten Menschen der Erde da jetzt mal so richtig aufräumen gegen die da oben.
Die da oben, ja, von wegen. Ja, das ist also schon fast tragisch,
was dort abläuft, muss ich sagen.
Es findet auch alles sehr viel schneller statt, als ich damit gerechnet hatte.
Aber offensichtlich scheint der Wille, die Welt in Flammen zu setzen,
bei Elon Musk sehr ausgeprägt zu sein,
und sein Vizepräsident Donald Trump scheint nicht so richtig willens oder in
der Lage zu sein, ihm dann in irgendeiner Form Grenzen zu setzen.
Ja. Das ist also man kann das eigentlich oder es wird ja von vielen,
ich glaube zu Recht, als Q bezeichnet, was da passiert.
Ja.
Und zwar gibt es jetzt das Department of Government Efficiency.
Doge. Nicht durch Zufall nach dem Mem, das Elon Musk ja sehr gefällt.
Und das ja auch schon mit dem Dogecoin vor vielen Jahren er bemüht hat,
dass eigentlich eine Meme-Coin in astronomische Höhen getwittert.
Ist eine neue, neu gegründete, in keiner Form irgendwie traditionell legitimierte
Einrichtung, die jetzt überall reinrennt in,
Bundesbehörden im Prinzip und sagt, Leute, geht uns aus dem Weg,
gibt mal die Daten und wir schmeißen jetzt ja alle raus.
Sie haben irgendwie Programme für Diversity, Equity und Inclusion rausgeworfen.
Das USAID, also im Prinzip das,
Entwicklungshilfe ist das,
Department of Education und dann warte, was war das?
NOAA NOAA,
National Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration haben sie jetzt auch schon,
Klimaüberwachung und so weiter, ja genau, also alles was so Rechte hassen und
alles was irgendwie dem Big Money und dem fossilen Industriewesen auch nur entfernt
in irgendeiner Form im Wege stehen kann, das wird jetzt einfach mal gnadenlos abgeräumt.
Und im Falle von USAID ist es, das ist jetzt sagen wir mal wirklich von all
den Casualties, von denen man jetzt bisher erfahren hat, abgesehen von dem Perch,
den sie jetzt offensichtlich auch bei der CIA vorhaben,
ist es schon mal so das krasseste, weil USAID ist jetzt definitiv eine der wichtigsten
Organisationen, sag ich mal, um.
Die,
Meinung, die die Welt von den USA hat, hochzuhalten.
Weil USAID, wie der Name schon sagt, unterstützt eben, das heißt da sind Nahrungsprogramme dabei,
das sind halt aber auch vor allem, ist es die Finanzierung von Journalisten,
die unabhängig berichten in Diktaturen etc.
Also all diese ganzen Gelder wurden jetzt eingefroren Und damit werden halt
sehr viele Leute arbeitslos.
Und so wie der Musk da jetzt gerade vorgeht, kann man sogar davon ausgehen,
dass dort auch die Arbeit von vielen Leuten gefährdet ist.
Es gibt jetzt auch gerade das Gerücht, dass da in irgendwelchen E-Mails Namenslisten
aufgetaucht sind von Leuten, die in China und anderen Ländern quasi als Informanten arbeiten,
wenn die halt jetzt alle dadurch auffliegen.
Das kann Leben kosten, das wird Leben kosten und es wird vor allem den USA sehr
viel negative Meinung einbringen in der nächsten Zeit.
Es ist vollkommen unklar, was es ist. Ich meine, es gibt da diese Story,
Elon Musk ist ja aus Südafrika und gehört da sozusagen zu so einer Familie,
denen ja auch Minen gehören etc.
Und USAID war auch sehr instrumental damit beschäftigt, damals diese Arbeit
zu überwinden in Südafrika.
Und das kann man also durchaus auch noch so als Rachefeldzug sehen.
Trump hat ja dann auch irgendwie rumgetwittert mit, ja, irgendwie,
das gehen ja unglaubliche Menschenrechtsverletzungen dort ab in Südafrika,
ja, weil ja gegen Weiße vorgegangen wird, wäre ja Rassismus.
Also das ist auch ein wirklich unterberichtetes Thema, die Benachteiligung der Weißen in Südafrika.
Ja, überhaupt der Weißen auch so, ne?
Ja, das ist wirklich, also huiuiui. Zum Gendern werden die da nämlich gezwungen auf einmal.
Gott, das ist ja Folter. Ja, also es ist völlig absurd und die eigentliche Frage,
die ich mir jetzt eben stelle und die ich selber nicht beantworten kann,
ist, wie resilient ist die USA tatsächlich?
Ja, ist ja im Prinzip eine Frage, die wir uns in Bezug auf Deutschland eben
auch schon gestellt haben.
Die Situation ist vielleicht bei uns gerade noch ein bisschen anders,
nicht ganz so eskaliert, aber ich glaube, dass das etwas ist,
wo wir auch schnell hinkommen können. Aber in den USA ist das jetzt,
glaube ich, der finale Test.
Also wenn sie sich gegen so etwas nicht wehren können, dann kann sich die USA
halt gegen gar nichts wehren.
Und wenn sich die USA nicht dagegen wehren kann und wenn also jetzt sozusagen
die USA binnen Monaten in so einen turbokapitalistischen Vollfascho-Revenschismusbehörde
umgewandelt wird, ja, die einfach…,
mehr oder weniger jetzt von behördlichen Strukturen in mafiöse Strukturen überführt wird.
Dann bricht damit natürlich die Sicherheitsordnung des ganzen Planeten auseinander.
Weil wenn diese Schutzrolle,
die die USA bisher übernommen haben, die ja zumindest auch teilweise altruistisch
formuliert war, die sicherlich auch was mit wirtschaftlichen Interessen zu tun
hat, das scheint aber wiederum Donald Trump nicht zu interessieren,
Aber wenn das halt wegbricht, dann wird es sportlich.
Dann muss sich halt Europa mehr denn je fragen.
Nicht erst in Zukunft, sondern meiner Auffassung nach jetzt,
wie wir uns da sicherheitstechnisch aufstellen wollen, weil dann ist sozusagen
die Schutzmacht weggebrochen.
Und es wird eben auch dazu führen, dass weltweit noch sehr viel mehr Krisen und Kriege ausbrechen.
Weil natürlich jetzt alle sehen, ah okay, die USA sind im Wesentlichen mit sich
selber beschäftigt, die interessiert jetzt die Welt nicht mehr,
die wollen jetzt nirgendwo mehr irgendwelche Einsätze fahren,
sondern die wollen jetzt irgendwie nur noch im Gaza-Streifen irgendwelche Hotels
bauen, na dann können wir ja jetzt auch irgendwie schön durchdrehen.
Ich denke, dass viel von dem, was Trump so von sich gibt, auch nach wie vor
einfach wirres Zeug ist und dass alles, was irgendwie zwei Wochen alt ist,
dann auch schon wieder irgendwie vom Tisch verschwindet.
Das Problem ist nur, was seine ganzen Cronies und allen voran natürlich Elon
Musk parallel jetzt eben mit dieser neu gefundenen Macht tun,
um sich sozusagen ihre Pründe zu sichern, ihre Rache auszuüben und so weiter.
Und dabei werden halt Behörden, Strukturen, Organisationen und am Ende vor allem
auch sehr viele Menschen sehr großen Schaden nehmen und das alles außergewöhnlich
beunruhigt, was da gerade passiert.
Was ich wirklich nicht verstehe,
also der Einfluss der USA in dieser Welt.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das mittel- und langfristig den stärkt,
was der Trump jetzt gerade macht.
Überhaupt nicht. Null.
Also kurzfristig schon. Ich meine, der tritt der Welt gerade richtig in den
Arsch. Der macht Roundhouse-Arschtritte.
Und man muss auch sagen, dass ich du erinnerst dich an dieses Bild,
was war das denn vom G8 oder,
wo Trump da irgendwie mit verschränkten Armen sitzt und alle anderen irgendwie
sagen so, Junge wir sind hier nicht im Kindergarten oder so,
sondern wir müssen hier gerade unserer Verantwortung gerecht werden.
Das,
Also, dass das, was der gerade tut, scheint ja, also ist halt wirklich widersinnig.
Und für das, was man von einem Präsidenten der USA erwarten würde,
ist natürlich klar, dass der sagt, okay, ich vertrete US-amerikanische Interessen
und ich baue unsere Macht aus.
Also sowas wie, was wir in der letzten Sendung besprochen hatten,
ich nehme 500 Milliarden und kippe die in eine potenzielle Zukunftstechnologie. In Ordnung.
Aber sowas wie, ach so, genau, wir machen jetzt eine Riviera-Hotellandschaft
am Gazastreifen und das ist ja völliger Irrsinn.
Also da wird der sicher, also das wird nicht stattfinden. Natürlich nicht.
Und wenn, dann wird es da sehr ungemütlich sein, Urlaub zu machen.
Aber die Länder, denen er da jetzt so in den Arsch tritt,
die haben es ja zumindest, sagen wir mal, die letzten vier Jahre US-Trump-Präsidentschaft
nicht wirklich geschafft, sich dem Typen einfach mal als Weltengemeinschaft entgegenzustellen.
Ganz im Gegenteil.
Hier Christian Lindner hat ja noch vor ein paar Wochen gesagt,
hier ey, mehr Millet und Musk wagen.
Also ich meine, gut, der ist Christian Lindner. Aber auch die Europäische Union
hat es nicht vollbracht,
diesen Typen auszubremsen, weil er noch diese Macht ausübt, die die USA haben und die dahinter steht.
Und deswegen kann er gerade machen, was er will und kurzfristig ist das eben
eine Verstärkung des Einflusses, aber es ist halt glaube ich,
langfristig wird sich das so nicht stabilisieren lassen, wenn alle denken mit
dem Land kannst du nicht mehr,
reden, mit dem kannst du auch keine Vereinbarung treffen, wenn du Pech hast,
macht der dir morgen eine Riviera oder er kennt,
deine,
Souveränität nicht mehr an und sagt, ach hier ich hab mir überlegt,
Kanada will ich haben ich will Kanada haben und Grönland und da machen wir eine
Riviera hin, welches Land will der noch haben?
Grönland.
Grönland, Kanada, sonst noch was?
Ach, der nimmt eigentlich alles, was Panama war, glaube ich, noch in der Diskussion.
Ja, Panama-Kanal wollte er noch zurückhaben.
Ja gut, ich meine, seine Methode ist halt beliebig irgendwelche bekloppten Drohungen auszusprechen.
Alles erstmal skandalisieren, Hauptsache alle reden über ihn.
Das ist ja das Hauptproblem. Also dieses ganze Nachplappern von seinen Meinungsäußerungen
ist schon mal Teil der Strategie.
Und das ist ja genau das, da waren wir eben schon bei der AfD in der ganzen
Kommunikation und so weiter.
Es geht einfach nur darum, Feinde schaffen und Aufmerksamkeit erzeugen.
Hauptsache alle reden über einen und alle haben irgendwie Angst vor irgendwas.
Und diese ganze diffuse Angstkulisse, dass man überhaupt nicht weiß,
was kommt jetzt als nächstes und was könnte jetzt alles noch kommen,
das treibt halt auch alle in dieses Appeasement mit rein.
Alle wollen sich irgendwie am Ende wegducken und nicht die Geschädigten sein.
Und du kannst dir vorstellen, dass in Europa auch ein erhöhter Windelbedarf
gerade besteht, weil sie halt alle Angst haben, jetzt von der nächsten Tarifrunde
getroffen zu werden oder sonst wie.
Also da ist glaube ich eine ganze Menge Scheißerei incoming.
Und ja gut, ich kann dir auch nicht sagen, was die beste Strategie dagegen ist,
aber sicherlich besteht sie nicht darin, ihn permanent ernst zu nehmen.
Am Ende muss man halt schauen, was tut er wirklich. Auch diese ganzen Tariffs,
also die ganzen Zollerhebungen, zusätzliche Zollerhebungen auf kanadische und
mexikanische Währung, das ist ja dann auch verpufft innerhalb von einem Tag.
Ja, jetzt hier 25% auf alle Waren und 10% auf Energie und am Ende hat er so
viel Gegenwind bekommen sogar vom Wall Street Journal.
Dass er da auch wieder einen Rückzieher machen müsste. Also viel wird,
glaube ich, auch scheitern.
Und am Ende, das hatte ich ja schon gesagt, wird es wirklich von der Resilienz
der amerikanischen Gesellschaft abhängen.
Okay, aber da siehst du jetzt, also das ist richtig, die Resilienz der amerikanischen
Gesellschaft, okay, eine Sache.
Aber aktuell, wenn wir mal kurz unsere Kurve zu Doge versuchen,
die Resilienz der aktuell der amerikanischen Regierungsinstitutionen.
Und das ist, also es wird ja tatsächlich wahrscheinlich auch zu Recht als Kuh
bezeichnet, dass da jetzt gerade, also ich meine, der reichste Mensch der Welt,
marschiert mit irgendwelchen Leuten Hackern.
Mit so jungen Hackern.
Genau, mit irgendwelchen, also naja, mit irgendwelchen Computer-Freaks,
in die Regierungsgebäude rein, die sich nicht ausweisen und sagt,
so die Daten, gib mal die Daten hier bitte.
So, zack, das kommt jetzt hier eine KI.
Der Kevin, der macht das jetzt in eine KI. Und dann gucken wir mal,
wen von euch will hier feuern.
Also das ist schlimm. Das ist ja absoluter Wahnsinn.
Und die Institutionen,
Die halt bisher immer noch irgendwie mit Leuten zu tun hatten,
die das gleiche Spiel gespielt haben.
Nämlich zum Beispiel, es gibt einen Rechtsweg oder sowas.
Oder es gibt einen formalen Prozess für etwas, dafür sind Demokratien ja da.
Die stehen jetzt da und sagen, ja krass, bis wir den Scheiß,
der hier angerichtet wird,
vor irgendwelchen mit den Wehrmethoden der Demokratie in den Griff bekommen
haben, beispielsweise irgendwelche Schnellgericht oder sonst was,
ist der Schaden ja längst angerichtet.
Der ist ja, also die rennen da jetzt einfach durch.
Sie hat irgendwie diese Treasury, der hat ja sogar Ausgaben der Treasury,
also quasi, wo der Staat gebilligte Ausgaben durch den Kongress hat,
hat er gesagt, nee, stopp, machen wir nicht mehr.
Wird jetzt nicht mehr bezahlt. Ende. Hat Elon Musk gesagt, so ungefähr.
Das ist Naja, das ist aber genau das, was ich meine.
Jetzt wird also wirklich der Staat und die gesamte Gesellschaft auf ihre Resilienz
geprüft, weil machen wir uns mal nichts vor, würde irgendjemand in Deutschland genauso los ragen,
uns einfach alles ignorieren und irgendwelche kleinen Staatsbedienstete,
da steht dann irgendwie so eine Armada von Leuten, die da irgendwie reinkommen
mit Sonnenbrillen und sagt, jetzt musst du das hier aber tun.
Dann wird der nicht in Ruhe zum Regal gehen, das Grundgesetz rausholen und Seite
350 aufschlagen und sagen so, ihr habt es ja wohl nicht alle,
sondern die werden da genauso sich wegducken und in das, ich habe ja nur getan, was mir gesagt wurde,
zurückziehen.
So wie wir das bei Polizeiverhalten auch immer schon gesehen haben.
Es ist nicht einfach eine Automatik, dass dann immer alle das Richtige tun,
sondern in gewisser Hinsicht ist so ein Staat auch immer innerhalb eines Modus operandi.
So haben wir das schon immer gemacht und das ist hier so der Normalfall und
so hat sich das hier einfach eingebürgert.
Genauso wie es halt in Staaten, wo eben ein Rechtssystem nicht greift,
auch sich alles in so einem Normalzustand des permanenten Bevorteilens einzelner
mächtigen Gruppen eingenordet hat.
Da kannst du wahrscheinlich auch mal so ein bisschen aus der Perspektive eines
Sicherheitsexperten drüber nachdenken.
Also wie kriegt man ein System, in dem Fall halt so ein Gesellschaftsstaatssystem,
per se auch sicher organisiert?
Ja, also warum kann denn ein Elon Musk auf diese Daten zugreifen?
Na, weil es halt Mitarbeiter gibt, die, wenn die einfach einknicken,
auch diesen Zugriff in dem Moment haben.
Ja, und dann kann das sofort einfach umgangen werden.
Also müsste man vielleicht darüber nachdenken, wie das sozusagen an der Stelle gar nicht geht.
Wer darf in der Bank… Du meinst.
Man müsste die Daten gar nicht erst sammeln?
Naja, gut, die Daten musst du halt sammeln, weil ich meine, das ist irgendwie
die Payroll des Staates, die brauchst du ja auch.
Das ist eher so die Frage, wie viele Schlüssel brauchst du, um den Tresor der Bank zu öffnen.
Und das ist ein technikalischer Nebenaspekt.
Ich sage nur einfach diese Erwartung, dass der Staat immer automatisch das Richtige
tut, wenn sich eben die Mächtigen oder die von den Mächtigen in irgendeiner
Form mächtig gemachten daneben verhalten und die Regeln ignorieren,
dann geht es einfach alles sehr schnell vor die Hunde.
Und da ist auch Deutschland, glaube ich, nicht viel besser aufgestellt.
Wenn so ein, ja, wenn Faschofritzer dann irgendwie ankommt und sagt,
wir machen das jetzt mal alles anders,
dann dauert das einfach eine Weile, bis du ein Rechtssystem hast,
was dann reinkickt und wo dann.
Auch protestiert wird und auch wirklich mal Widerspruch eingelegt wird und dann
auch wirklich ein Gericht irgendwas entscheidet und wir haben das ja auch in
Deutschland in letzter Zeit,
erlebt, mir fällt jetzt gerade das Beispiel nicht ein, dass halt auch einfach,
Gesetzesentscheidungen, die dann also Gerichtsentscheidungen,
die getroffen worden sind schlichtweg einfach ignoriert wurden.
Die wurden dann einfach nicht getan.
Was war denn das Beispiel? Das hatten wir doch irgendwie im letzten Jahr irgendeinen Fall.
Ich kriege es gerade nicht zusammen. Aber am Ende irgendeiner muss es ja auch tun.
Diese Rechtspflege muss ja dann auch durchgeführt werden.
Und wenn du so ein System niemals in so einer Stresssituation auch wirklich,
getestet hast, ich meine, wir machen alle Feuerübungen und da wird mal die Sirene
gemacht und da laufen alle auf den Hof.
Ob die da im Finanzministerium auch mal den Sirenentest gemacht haben mit,
was ist, wenn jetzt hier so ein,
topokapitalistisches Arschloch reinkommt und sagt, ich will jetzt mal eine Daten haben.
Christian Lindner?
Naja, choose your poison. Also in dem Fall halt dieser Vollidiot Elon Musk,
der mit Sicherheit irgendein ganz tiefes psychologisches Problem hat,
aber das kann uns jetzt auch erstmal egal sein, was der Grund dafür ist,
der Typ dreht einfach frei und hat viel zu viel Geld und viel zu viel Einfluss.
Das dazu.
Es ist wirklich, ja, okay, kommen wir zu anderen schönen Nachrichten.
Nein, haben wir noch so schöne.
Also Daten spielen natürlich, und deswegen haben wir ja so ein bisschen,
Daten spielen in dieser ganzen Sache natürlich eine Rolle.
Also diese ganzen digital erfassten Daten schnappt sich der Typ da jetzt,
hat jetzt auch, und da spielt natürlich KI eine Rolle.
Also ich bin jetzt mal gespannt, diese Idee mit dem, gib mal die ganzen Daten,
ich kipp die jetzt mal in eine KI.
Das ist ja potenziell auch gar nicht so ein schlechter Ansatz,
eventuell überhaupt dieser Sache Herr werden zu können und die verstehen zu können.
Also diese Vereinzelung, Bürokratisierung,
Prozesshaftigkeit, die ja in einer Demokratie, und ich bin wirklich kein Fan von Bürokratie,
den Zweck hat, Dinge auszubremsen.
Und jetzt geht er da hin und sagt, zack, das machen wir jetzt hier mit einer
KI und dann gucken wir mal, wir hauen jetzt hier drauf und schmeißen alle raus.
Und Elon Musk hat ja, wenn du dir irgendwie anschaust, was der schon so getan
hat in seinem Leben, mitunter erstaunliche Ergebnisse erzielt,
indem er Systeme enorm unter Druck gesetzt hat.
Indem er einfach, weiß nicht, bei Twitter braucht auf jeden Fall für seine X
ein paar tausend Leute weniger als Twitter vorher brauchte.
Und das Ding funktioniert zur Zeit noch.
Und zwar noch dazu in seinem Sinne. Will keiner mehr Anzeigen schalten,
deswegen verklagt er die Leute, weil sie bei ihm nicht Kunde sind oder so.
Völlig bescheuert, aber so hat er sich das ja offenbar vorgestellt. Und.
Ich denke schon, wenn man jetzt mal diese ganzen antidemokratischen,
völligen irrsinnigen Aspekte da,
außen vor lässt, dass der mit dieser ganzen Doge-Nummer potenziell noch eine lange Zeit,
Erfolge feiern kann, im Sinne von das macht er ja, die gehen ja heute hin und
sagen, guck mal hier, wie viel Geld wir jetzt schon wieder gespart haben,
indem wir diese Leute rausgeworfen haben.
Und ich glaube, dieses Spiel kann ja noch relativ lange spielen.
Und alles, was passieren wird, ist, der reißt ja nur Kontrollen und Checks und
Balances da ein, wo sie ihnen im Weg stehen.
Das heißt, da wird jetzt so schnell auch niemand sagen, dass etwas, was er getan hat,
ein Schnitt ins eigene Fleisch war.
Und das macht mir die Sorgen, weil der da im Prinzip die ganze Zivilisation,
den ganzen Anstand, die ganze Demokratie abbauen kann und da jeden Tag hinkommt
und sagt, guck mal, was ich hier schon wieder kaputt gemacht habe und alle so,
yeah, voll geil, voll geil,
jetzt noch fünf Mexikaner hier rauswerfen, dann habe ich wieder einen Job.
Ein Job, den ich nie haben wollte.
Und vor dem Hintergrund, ich
denke, dass da die Dateninterpretations- und Verarbeitungsmöglichkeiten,
die mit der sogenannten künstlichen Intelligenz einhergehen,
durchaus eine größere Rolle spielen,
solche Aktionen machen zu können.
Und da hat nach unserer letzten Sendung, wo wir sehr beeindruckt waren davon,
dass Trump da diese Stargate-Initiative bekannt gegeben hat und gesagt hat,
hier eine halbe Trilliarde wird in diese Technologie gekippt.
Und kurz darauf gab es dann die Bekanntgabe Chinas, dass mit DeepSeek ein Modell
geschaffen wurde, also ein Large Language Model,
das ähnlich gut wie ChatGPT funktioniert, also mit ChatGPT vergleichbare Fähigkeiten
hat und dessen Training nur einen Bruchteil dessen gekostet hat.
Und eine sehr interessante Meldung, die dazu geführt hat, dass Nvidia,
der Schaufelverkäufer des KI-Goldrausches, ich glaube 17% ist die Aktie gefallen,
hat damit 16 Billionen oder was auch immer an Wert verloren.
Und damit den größten absoluten Wertverlust eines Unternehmens in der Historie
von Wertverlusten einzelner Unternehmen geschaffen hat.
Also der größte absolute Wertverlust in der Geschichte einer Börse, in einem Einzelwert.
Ist nicht schlimm, ist immer noch viel zu teuer die Aktie. und haben sich natürlich
auch erholt, zu großen Teilen.
Aber der Gedanke, der dahinter steckte, war, naja, wenn neuronale Modelle zu
trainieren doch nicht so aufwendig ist und so viel Compute braucht, wie alle denken,
dann werden ja auch Leute weniger bei Nvidia kaufen müssen, um gleiche Ergebnisse zu erzielen.
Und deswegen gab es quasi diese Börsenreaktion.
Es gibt aber natürlich dementsprechend für alle, die keine Aktien von Nvidia
haben, eigentlich die Hoffnung zu sagen, ach so super, China hat quasi ein derartiges
Ergebnis mit sehr viel weniger Geld hinbekommen, hat ja vielleicht Europa auch nochmal eine Chance.
Weil wir ja nicht 500 Milliarden irgendwo reinkippen, sondern ...
500 Euro mit unter, wenn die übrig sind.
Und müssen wir nochmal gucken, vielleicht finden wir noch welche. Und,
ich habe gesehen, dass ihr in der Freakshow, ich habe es gesehen,
ich habe es wirklich gesehen, dass ihr in der Freakshow darüber geredet habt,
weil ich habe es noch nicht gehört.
Wie ist das denn jetzt, Tim? Gibt es jetzt bald EU-GPT?
Und,
also wo du deinen Optimismus jetzt auf einmal für Europa in diesem ganzen Spiel
hernimmst, ist mir ehrlich gesagt ein Rätsel, weil ich meine,
wenn irgendeiner bei dieser ganzen Geschichte nun überhaupt gar keine Aktien
hat, dann ist es halt Europa.
Also Europa findet einfach AI-technisch derzeit einfach überhaupt nicht statt.
Nicht, dass hier nicht irgendwo mal ein bisschen rumgeforscht wird,
aber ich glaube spätestens seit diesem EU-AI-Act kann man jetzt irgendwie Forschung
und AI wahrscheinlich jetzt für die nächste Zeit in Europa erstmal so komplett beiseite legen.
Das wird hier einfach nicht stattfinden, sondern das findet halt in den USA
statt und das findet jetzt, wie man festgestellt hat, vor allem in China statt.
Und was ja hier stattgefunden hat, um das mal so ein bisschen auszumalen,
war, die USA haben versucht,
über ein Technikembargo China da klein zu halten, indem sie Nvidia verboten
haben, eine bestimmte Performance-Kategorie von Chips dort zu verkaufen.
Was dann dazu führte, dass es so Stripped-Down-Versionen gab von entsprechenden
GPUs, die in bestimmten Charakteristika eben bewusst klein gehalten waren.
Also konkret so eine Interchip-Kommunikation spielt das technisch alles nicht
so eine große Rolle, das zu verstehen. Also sie mussten dort offiziell zumindest
mit etwas weniger auskommen.
Inwiefern solche Embargi dann auch wirklich greifen, das ist nochmal eine ganz andere Frage.
Kannst du dir vorstellen, ich meine das wird dann irgendwie alles vor den Toren
Chinas produziert in Taiwan und dann willst du mir erzählen,
es gibt irgendwie keinen Weg da diese Wasserstraße mal zu überqueren für so eine Lieferung.
Das kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht vorstellen.
Trotzdem offiziell war das eben so.
Und jetzt gibt es natürlich da auch noch gleich viele Verschwörungstheorien,
die gesagt haben, ja, die haben zwar gesagt, sie hätten auf diese Technologie
keinen Zugriff gehabt, aber wer weiß schon, ob das wirklich stimmt.
Letztlich ist es so, wenn man sich das technische Ergebnis anschaut,
was DeepSeek dort veröffentlicht hat, gibt es schon sehr klare Anhaltspunkte
dafür, dass das durchaus Hand und Fuß hat.
Weil sie haben halt ganz klar nachvollziehbare technische Maßnahmen ergriffen,
um ihre Art und Weise, wie sie ihr Modell trainiert haben,
anders aufzustellen und dabei eben weniger von der Hardware abzuhängen,
beziehungsweise sie haben halt optimierteren Code geschrieben.
Von daher kann bezweifelt werden, dass dieses Embargo da wirklich viel zur Folge hatte.
Aber es gibt auch ein paar ganz gute Nachrichten in diesem ganzen Zusammenhang.
Nämlich erstens, dass sie ihr Modell ja nicht nur entwickelt und vorgestellt
und demonstriert haben, sondern sie haben es ja dann eben auch in der fertig
trainierten Version veröffentlicht. Da sind sie auch nicht die einzigen, die das machen.
Meta hat das ja getan mit seinem Lama-Modell, Alibaba macht das mit seinem Quen-Modell,
das sind ja alles so Modelle, wo auch dann viel dran rumgerechnet und rumgetestet wird.
Nur OpenAI und Google halten ihre Modelle ja sozusagen noch closed.
Und es kann durchaus sein,
dass diese DeepSeek-Entwicklung jetzt auch ein Indiz dafür ist,
dass die eigentliche Beschleunigung in diesem ganzen AI-Development-Business
über solche Open-Source-Modelle läuft.
Wobei man jetzt ein bisschen vorsichtig sein muss mit dem Begriff Open Source.
Genau genommen ist es ja kein Open Source Modell.
Ja, es ist kein Source.
Ja, also die Methodiken ist halt veröffentlicht, das Modell ist veröffentlicht
worden, aber es sind ja nicht die Daten veröffentlicht worden,
mit denen halt die Dinger initial trainiert wurden.
Von daher ist es ja nicht im eigentlichen Sinne komplett nachvollziehbar,
aber es ist halt nutzbar.
Und der zweite Aspekt hier ist dieses DeepSeq R1, also dieses spezielle sogenannte Reasoning-Model,
was auf dem eigentlichen Large-Language-Model, was sie auch noch rausgebracht
haben im letzten Dezember schon, das V3-Modell von ihnen,
deshalb so gut geworden ist, weil sie eine andere Trainingsmethode gemacht haben
und eben hier erst mal nicht mit riesiger Computing-Performance das gemacht
haben und auch nicht umgekehrt.
Basis weiterer Daten aus dem Internet. Das ist ja so eine permanente Diskussion
mit, wo sollen die ganzen Daten herkommen und wenn das ganze Internet nur noch
aus AI-Slope besteht, worauf willst du dann überhaupt noch ordentlich trainieren?
Diese Verbesserung, dieses Reasoning hat dieses Modell dadurch erfahren,
indem sie quasi diese Techniken, die ja auch nichts Neues sind.
Wie man sie in der Robotik kennt, so Reinforcement Learning,
also dass sozusagen das Modell sich selbst trainiert und einfach sich selber seine Aufgaben stellt.
Das ist ja relativ offensichtlich bei so Sachen wie Schach und Go,
da kannst du quasi die Modelle gegen sich selbst antreten lassen und dann weißt du ja,
was dazu führt, dass man ein Spiel gewinnt und dadurch wird es immer besser
und ein Roboter merkt halt irgendwie, wenn er auf die Fresse fällt oder ob er
jetzt geschafft hat, besser zu laufen.
Das sind also sozusagen selbstmessbare Vorgänge und sie Wir haben halt für das
Trainieren von dem System selber Methoden entwickelt und wie die sich sozusagen
selber verbessern kann.
Und das ist irgendwie ziemlich bemerkenswert und letzten Endes eben ist es auch
noch geschafft, mit sehr viel weniger Ressourcen zu arbeiten.
Also wir reden hier von so einer Verminderung des Ressourcenbedarfs um Faktor 100 ungefähr.
Also mit 100 mal weniger Ressourcen kannst du so ein Modell trainieren und 100
mal weniger Ressourcen kannst du auch dieses Modell benutzen.
Sprich, auf einmal brauchst du gar nicht mehr so einen großen Rechnerpark,
sowohl um es zu trainieren, als auch um es zu nutzen.
Und es ist durchaus absehbar, dass wir jetzt in den nächsten ein,
zwei, drei Jahren sehen werden, dass das noch so weitergeht oder sich vielleicht
sogar in der Entwicklung noch weiter beschleunigt.
Und dass diese ganze Aufregung mit AI verbraucht mehr Strom,
als der Planet Photonen empfängt von der Sonne.
Ein bisschen vorschnell war und dass das gelingt, das so weit zu optimieren,
dass solche Modelle was vollkommen Normales werden.
Und...
Aber es gab ja dann schon Diskussionen darüber, dass dieser Effizienzgewinn,
der da behauptet wurde, vielleicht gar nicht in der Form da war?
Also dass quasi die Angaben nicht stimmen würden?
Ja, die Diskussionen gab es, aber dafür gibt es ehrlich gesagt so richtig keine
Anhaltspunkte, weil das Modell ist ja nachweislich effizient.
Also man kann es sich ja runterladen und man kann es irgendwie auf dem Computer
ausführen und man merkt ja, wie viel Aufwand man hat und dieses Paper,
was sie vorgestellt haben,
zeigt ja auch die Methoden, die sie verwendet haben, um ihren Trainingsbedarf
zu reduzieren, relativ klar auf.
Das hat was damit zu tun, dass eben nicht immer das ganze Modell aktiviert werden
muss, um es zu trainieren.
Das ist so diese Aufteilung mit verschiedenen Sub-Experten und es wird auch
vermutet, dass auch bei OpenAI solche Techniken schon zum Einsatz kamen und
verschiedene andere Maßnahmen,
um den Speicherbedarf dieser Systeme zu reduzieren und den Kommunikationsbedarf,
was auch dazu geführt hat, dass sie eben nicht so schnellere Chips dafür brauchten,
um dieses Training durchzuführen.
Also bisher habe ich relativ wenig gesehen, was von Leuten, die das jetzt technisch
bewerten können, ich bin ja alles andere als ein AI-Experte,
ich plapper hier auch nur nach, was ich jetzt alles gehört habe.
Machen wir grundsätzlich in diesem Podcast.
Ja genau, so macht man das halt im Podcast.
Ich habe bisher noch keine Bewertung gehört von Leuten, die das technisch verstehen,
die sagen, das kann alles nicht sein.
Der Einzige, der sich beschwert hat, war irgendwie Sam Altman,
der gesagt hat, oh Skandal, benutzen unsere Daten, um ihr Modell zu trainieren, was erlaube China.
Ja, und alle haben natürlich jetzt irgendwie total Schiss, dass sie irgendwie
ihre Investitionsgelder verlieren, weil das ist ja letztendlich hinter diesem
Kursverlust, dass auf einmal diese Einschätzung mit, ja braucht ihr denn überhaupt so viel Geld,
geht das nicht vielleicht auch mit ein bisschen weniger, investieren wir hier
vielleicht in irgendetwas, wo die anderen dann einfach Hase und Igel mäßig an
uns vorbeiziehen und sagen, wir sind schon längst da.
Also das ähm.
Kann ich auch nicht abschließend beurteilen, aber das war, sagen wir mal,
der Hintergrund dieser ganzen Aufregung.
Man muss aber auch eben jetzt klar sehen, China ist da jetzt einfach mal mit ganz vorne dabei.
Konkret ist es vor allem aber auch diese Firma DeepSeek, die halt von so einem
total krassen Mathe-Nerd irgendwie gegründet wurde,
der so ein richtiger Superbrain ist im mathematischen Bereich und der vorher
ja auch schon sehr viel Geld verdient hat, mit sowohl Bitcoin-Mining als auch
Trading-Software-Optimierung.
Also da kommen die her und haben sich jetzt sozusagen dann so aus Langeweile
auch noch dem Thema AI zugewendet und binnen weniger Jahre jetzt große Fortschritte gemacht.
Und es kann durchaus sein, dass das noch so weitergeht.
China setzt seit langer, langer, langer Zeit auch im Technologiebereich eben Aufbildung.
Da gibt es einfach eine krasse Ausbildungsmentalität, um Leute wirklich top-notch auszubilden.
Und das ist eben auch die Basis dieses großen technologischen Sprungs,
den China gemacht hat, der sich jetzt im Computing zeigt, der sich jetzt vielleicht
demnächst auch in Software zeigt, der
definitiv auch in der ganzen Elektronikentwicklung, Militärtechnik etc.
Also die bewegen sich einfach mit großen Schritten nach vorne.
Das kann einem jetzt passen oder nicht passen. Das ist einfach so.
Schau dir an, was China jetzt im Energiebereich geschafft hat.
China hat im letzten Jahr mehr Solarpanels installiert, als die USA in ihrer
ganzen Existenz jemals insgesamt installiert haben.
Das ist so die Dimension, in der wir jetzt hier gerade uns bewegen.
Und da wird es halt jetzt mit dem Rest genauso ablaufen.
Also da würde ich grundsätzlich, was die Entwicklung grundsätzlich neuer Technologien und Wachstum angeht,
ohnehin auf jeden Fall auf China setzen.
In dem Land gibt es ja auch noch einen Hunger, die können sich auch noch irgendwo
hin entwickeln das ist der andere Aspekt den ich gerne mal benenne dass wenn
du eine chinesische Person bist,
hast du blickst du in eine Welt der Möglichkeiten um dich herum, weil da alles noch,
da kannst du noch die ganzen Häuser bauen, da werden riesige Städte gebaut die
woanders auf dem Planeten noch nie in dieser Form existiert haben und überall
wird etwas gebraucht und geschaffen und gemacht.
In den USA sitzen irgendwelche bewaffneten Idioten ohne Zähne letztendlich in
der Wüste und beschweren sich, wenn ein japanisches Auto vorbeifährt oder so.
Das ist halt eine andere, einfach so eine andere Mentalität,
die die da dann entsteht.
Es gibt noch eine recht spannende Geschichte von Robert Bongen,
Lisa Maria Hagen, Tobias Hübers und Daniel Moosbrücker, die sich nochmal mit
dem Kampf gegen Pädokriminalität auseinandersetzen.
Wir haben das hier auch immer wieder behandelt.
Ich habe da mal mit Nancy Felser auch bei Markus Lanz drüber gesprochen.
Dass es Foren gibt, Darknet-Foren,
Telegram-Gruppen oder sonst was,
wo kriminelle Dokumentationen von Kindesmissbrauch teilen und verteilen.
Und weil diese Darknet-Strukturen, in denen sie ja dann quasi anonym sind.
Langsam sind, legen die in der Regel das Material, was sie dort tauschen und
verteilen, auf Shared-Hoster im normalen Internet.
Dann wird ja quasi eine verschlüsselte Datei oder sonst was.
Also im Prinzip weiß ich, inzwischen gibt es das ja nicht mehr,
Was früher Leute so bei RapidShare oder Mega oder wo auch immer,
ich weiß nicht, was es da heute gibt, aber irgendwo für alle zugänglichen Internet
werden diese großen Datenmengen dann gespeichert,
aber der Verweis dorthin findet eben auf eben diesen Darknet-Foren statt.
Und jetzt hat das eine Konsequenz, dass du nämlich, wenn du weißt,
dass es da solche Inhalte gibt, dem Hoster Bescheid geben kannst und natürlich
auch solltest und sagst, pass mal auf, da liegen illegale Inhalte,
lösch die doch mal bitte.
Oder man könnte natürlich auch zum Beispiel hingehen und sagen,
guck mal bitte, wer die hochgeladen hat, lass uns mal ein Strafverfahren einleiten.
Jedenfalls könnte man mal etwas unternehmen dagegen, wenn man doch sagt,
dass man gegen diesen Bereich der Kriminalität vorgehen möchte.
Was man ja tut, also es wird ja gesagt, man möchte dagegen vorgehen.
Damit wird begründet die Chat-Kontrolle, damit wird begründet jedes Mal wieder
die Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Vorratseitenspeicherung wird auch mit was anderem begründet,
wird auch mit Angriffen auf Kleinkinder in Einkaufsstraßen begründet.
Na, hat alles nichts damit zu tun, aber klar brauchen wir Vorratseitenspeicherung.
Und dieses Team ist dann mal hingegangen und hat gesagt,
also wir fordern es ja seit langem, Daniel Musburger insbesondere auch,
dass die Polizei, wenn sie doch diese Foren überwacht, dass sie dann halt diese
scheiß Inhalte löschen muss.
Und die Polizei vertritt irgendwie eine andere Meinung zu diesem Thema.
Nämlich, dass es irgendwie nicht zu ihrer Aufgabe gehört, die Verfügbarkeit
dieses Materials einzuschränken.
Und das überrascht mich dann doch sehr, weil die Tatsache ist ja,
das ist ja eine fortlaufende, aktuell stattfindende Straftat,
wenn da diese Verbreitung ist.
Also das Material wird dort angeboten, es kann dort heruntergeladen werden und
solange es dort angeboten wird, wird es verfügbar gemacht, also ist es eine
Straftat, die da stattfindet.
Und bei jeder anderen Straftat, wo ein Polizist daneben steht oder von der Polizist
Kenntnis hat, schreiten die ja ein, warum tun sie es denn da nicht,
tun sie es bis heute nicht.
Jetzt haben hier diese Journalistinnen angesagt, naja okay, dann machen wir
das jetzt halt und nehmen diese
Meldungen vor, was nochmal einen weiteren Aspekt hat, nämlich nicht nur,
also stoppst du damit eine Straftat, sondern du greifst natürlich auch diese
Foren in ihrer Existenz an und störst ihren Betrieb und du schützt die Opfer,
bei denen der Missbrauch mitunter lange oder auch noch nicht lange zurückliegt
und denen ja nun durch die Verbreitung dieses Materials jeden Tag weiterer Schmerz
zugefügt wird und Unrecht zugefügt wird.
Haben sie gemacht, war überhaupt gar kein Problem, haben einen großen Teil der
Verfügbarkeit derartigen Materials im Internet eingedämmt.
Müssen halt quasi ein paar motivierte...
Journalisten in ihrer ja letztendlich in ihrer frei verfügbaren,
sicherlich nicht für diese Tätigkeit bezahlten Zeit machen und die haben irgendwie
die verfügbaren Clearweb Bilder forenübergreifend zwischen die bewegten sich so irgendwie im am 21.
Juli irgendwie nördlich von 45.000 und die haben die Zahl runtergeprügelt auf in dem Bereich 1000.
Das ist schon also wirklich ein riesiger Effekt, den sie da hatten,
einfach nur durch konsequente Meldungen und Löschungen, die diese Foren,
sehr unter Druck gesetzt haben,
weil sie diese Tätigkeit nicht mehr betreiben konnten, weil ihnen andauernd
die Daten gelöscht wurden.
Hätte, wäre so eine Aufgabe gewesen, die ich bei der, wo ich gedacht hätte,
könnte ja die Polizei machen.
Ja, da sind wir wieder bei dem Punkt, wo eigentlich irgendwas beschlossen ist
und es müsste ja die normale Rechtsfolge müsste dann so eine Maßnahme ergeben,
aber irgendwie macht das dann keiner.
Ja, naja, das ist jetzt der Beschluss, das ist jetzt hier irgendwie das Recht,
aber naja, es hat ja auch was anderes zu tun.
Es ist schlimmer, die argumentieren ja sogar, sie haben ja immer alle möglichen
Ausreden, warum sie das nicht tun würden.
Das ist irgendwie nicht unsere Aufgabe. Wir haben bei Lanz gesagt,
wir machen das jetzt, aber nee, machen wir weiter nicht. Machen wir einfach nicht.
Ich würde gerne noch kurz mit dir reden über den Valomat, Tim.
Ja, gibt es wieder einen.
Hast du einen Valomat gemacht?
Nee, brauche ich nicht.
Ich habe Postillon Valomat gemacht.
Ach, den gibt es auch? Was kann man da herausfinden?
Kannst du zum Beispiel sagen, ich bin dafür, dass die Bundesregierung sich nach
kompetenten Politikern im Ausland umschaut, bevor das Verkehrsministerium wieder
an jemanden von der CSU geht?
Aus Südafrika?
Derartiges. Da müssen wir nochmal hier in die Shownotes nehmen.
Und es gibt einen von unseren Freunden bei Frag den Staat ein recht interessantes,
Projekt, wo ich schon, als ich davon hörte, dachte, das gibt Ärger.
Nämlich den Realomat.
Der Realomat,
stellt dir quasi die Positionen der Vergangenheit, also die im jetzigen Bundestag
diskutiert wurden und entschlossen wurden, vor und fragt dich, wie du denn dazu stehst.
Also quasi nicht, was steht im Wahlprogramm, was wird hier versprochen,
sondern wie stehst du denn zu dem, was passiert ist?
Ja.
Ja,
mit natürlich mitunter sehr spannenden Ergebnissen und einem großen Aufschrei,
weil du da natürlich die, sagen wir nicht die Verzerrung, aber die Konfundierung
durch die Ampelkoalition drin hast.
Der Realomat wirft also den Leuten etwas zu oft zu viel Übereinstimmung mit
der FDP aus, als dass sie mit dem Ergebnis zufrieden wären. Ja,
lässt sich aber natürlich, also lässt sich natürlich erklären, weil die Koalition,
wenn du jetzt also sagst, du stimmst mit vielen der Positionen von SPD und Grünen
überein, dann stimmst du eben automatisch auch mit Entscheidungen der FDP mit überein.
Was die Daten angeht, also ein ganz interessanter Effekt, der da eintritt und
für viele Leute eben ein überraschendes Ergebnis,
wenn sie dann sehen, ach so, meine Positionen wurden dann doch größtenteils
von den Grünen vertreten, wo ich doch eigentlich dachte, die wären doof,
weil sie hier eine Modernisierung des Landes anstreben oder sowas.
Fand ich ganz interessant. Und dann gibt es noch den Wahl-O-Mat.
Habe ich aber noch nicht gespielt. Sollen wir mal spielen?
Wahl-O-Mat? Sollen wir mal die Fragen durchgehen? Sind das viele?
Welchen Wahl-O-Mat meinst du jetzt? Den Real-O-Mat oder den OG?
OG?
Original Gangster.
Ah.
Also den richtig.
Du meinst ja einfach nur, der so durchliest, was die Parteien meinen,
was sie vielleicht unter Umständen tun würden.
Genau.
Na, aber da hält sich doch eh keiner dran.
Das ist, wir sollen doch hier ein bisschen positiver.
Optimistischer sein?
Ja.
Stimmt, mir wurde Pessimismus vorgeworfen.
Jetzt reiß dich doch mal. Reiß dich doch mal am Schiff.
Ich triff doch zu. Ich hab's jetzt nun jahrelang mit Optimismus probiert.
Bin's auch nur für verarscht für deine goldenen Zwanziger.
Was hat es mir gebracht? Du mit deinen goldenen Zwanziger. Und ich bin schuld
und so weiter. Ich bin schuld, weil ich optimistisch war.
Und dann ist es irgendwie nicht so gekommen. Oder es war nicht golden genug.
Und alle waren unzufrieden. Und dann bin ich jetzt der Doofe.
Aber dann bin ich mal pessimistisch und sag, es geht jetzt ja eh alles den Bach
runter. Was wollt ihr eigentlich?
Das ist auch wieder nicht richtig. Naja.
Aber so ganz interessante Themen.
Okay, dann mach mal.
Also okay, es sind 38 Fragen. Deutschland soll die Ukraine weiterhin militärisch unterstützen.
Jawohl.
Der Ausbau erneuerbarer Energien soll weiterhin vom Staat finanziell gefördert werden.
Das Bürgergeld soll für denjenigen gestrichen werden, für denjenigen gestrichen
werden, die wiederholt Stellenangebote ablehnen.
Für diejenigen wäre, glaube ich, kann ich sagen, der Satz ist nicht korrekt.
Auf allen Autobahnen soll ein generelles Tempolimit gelten.
Asylsuchende, die über einen anderen EU-Staat eingereist sind,
sollen an den deutschen Grenzen abgewiesen werden.
Bei Neuvermietungen sollen die Mietpreise weiterhin gesetzlich begrenzt werden.
An Bahnhöfen soll die Bundespolizei Software zur automatisierten Gesichtserkennung einsetzen dürfen.
Energieintensive Unternehmen sollen vom Staat einen finanziellen Ausgleich für
ihre Stromkosten erhalten.
Worauf willst du jetzt hinaus eigentlich ich meine das sind ja alles so einzelne
Sätze die so in diesem Wahlprogramm drinstehen oder die in mehr als einem drinstehen
und dann soll man sich da irgendwie zu beziehen,
mir ist das irgendwie zu ja weiß ich auch nicht, mich bringt das irgendwie nicht weiter.
Was du es gibt noch ein anderes Angebot das ist nämlich der Grund das suche ich mal schnell raus,
und zwar hat sich tatsächlich haben mehrere also es gibt mehrere derartige,
Initiativen zum
Beispiel gibt es fragdaswahlprogramm.de das
ist von einem unserer treuen Hörer gebaut worden der Sven steht auch im Impressum
der hat ein LLM mit den Wahlprogrammen der Parteien gefüttert.
Und dann kannst sie irgendwie das Ding fragen.
Also empfiehlt auch fragen, wie wollen die Parteien den Ärztemangel bekämpfen?
Wie stehen die Parteien zum Bau neuer Kernkraftwerke? Welche Parteien setzen
sich für kleinere Klassenstärken ein?
Oder was planen Grüne und BSW zur Förderung alternativer Heilmethoden? Das interessiert mich.
Gucken jetzt, dann durchsucht das Ding die Wahlprogramme. Also mit anderen Worten
fragt wahrscheinlich ChachiPT oder so.
Im Wahlprogramm von Bündnis 90 Die Grünen habe ich keine spezifischen Informationen
zur Förderung alternativer Heilmethoden gefunden.
Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht kritisiert die aktuelle Gesundheitsversorgung,
die sich auf teure Reparaturmedizin konzentriert und alternative Behandlungsformen
sowie Prävention vernachlässigen würde.
Es wird gefordert, dass alternative Heilmethoden und Psychotherapie stärker
in die Gesundheitsversorgung integriert werden, um die Bedürfnisse von Patienten besser zu erfüllen.
Die Partei BSW setzt sich für eine Gesundheits- und Pflegepolitik ein,
die eine gute Versorgung für alle Kranken- und Pflegebedürftigen sicherstellen
soll und die Zwei-Klassen-Medizin beendet.
So, dann kannst du jetzt mal zu deinen Themen.
Also wer will Tempolimit auf der Datenautobahn abschaffen?
Gucken was er sagt einen Moment jetzt kann ich mir die Parteien auswählen bei denen von denen achso.
Bei mir waren es nur vier ich weiß nicht warum.
Ich guck mal die Linke, die AfD Volt und Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht mal gucken was die dazu sagen,
jetzt sucht er das,
AfD? Ach, ne, okay. Er hat das automatisch auf Autobahn korrigiert.
Mich würden ja andere Sachen interessieren. Was ist das Durchschnitts-IQ von
allen, die auf der Liste dieser Partei stehen?
Ah, ja. Schätze den durchschnittlichen IQ der Autorin des,
jeweiligen Wahlprogramms.
Ich kann keine Einschätzung oder Bewertung zum IQ von Personen einschließlich
der Autorinnen und Autoren des Wahlprogramms abgeben.
Wenn du Fragen zu den Inhalten der Wahlprogramme oder den Positionen der Parteien
hast, helfe ich dir gerne weiter.
Schade.
Tja Sven, da muss noch mal ran. Wir schicken dir die Zahlen und dann weiß das
Ding die richtige Antwort.
Aber also die Idee ist doch nicht schlecht, dass man da jetzt Fragen stellen kann.
Nein, das ist alles völlig in Ordnung und ich finde es auch gut,
wenn sich Leute mit solchen Sachen beschäftigen Ich habe nur so ein bisschen,
ja, ich weiß nicht, also die Wahl
ist ja eigentlich relativ klar also ich meine, es gibt da nicht so viel,
nicht mehr so viel Auswahl weil man kann jetzt ja eigentlich also Herr Merz
hat es uns ja relativ einfach gemacht, also ist dir irgendwie alles egal und
willst du die Welt brennen sehen, dann gibt es halt sozusagen die eine Variante,
oder bist du dafür, dass man irgendwie noch so eine,
halbwegs gebildete Menschen an den Start bringt, die ein bisschen Dignity an
die Problematik herangehen, dann hast du so das andere Lager. Und ich finde,
klarer hätte die Wahl kaum ausfallen können dieses Mal.
Das Wahlangebot meinst du? Die Wahl ist ja noch gar nicht ausgefallen.
Ja, ja, das meine ich ja. Also was zur Wahl steht für einen sozusagen,
wie man sich da entscheiden muss.
Wer jetzt so ein Online-Tool braucht, um hier Orientierung zu finden,
dann frage ich mich wirklich, wie groß der Stein war, unter dem ihr jetzt die
letzten drei Jahre verbracht habt.
Also, ich finde das trotzdem mal nicht so blöd,
Also dieser Wahl-O-Mat oder auch der
Real-O-Mat oder hier frag mal die Wahlprogramme, das sind ja schon Tools,
die dir dabei helfen, eventuell ein von den Medien verzerrtes oder vielleicht
auch von deinen Gefühlen verzerrtes Bild zu korrigieren.
Oder die es dir überhaupt mal ermöglichen, dich zu einem politischen Thema zu
informieren, das du vielleicht für tatsächlich relevant hältst,
im Gegensatz zu denen, die diskutiert werden.
Also zum Beispiel könnte ja jemand zu der Einsicht gelangen,
dass eventuell, also nur so mal als richtig steile These,
dass die Probleme, die das Land gerade hat, überhaupt nicht im Bereich der Migration liegen.
Wenn eine solche Person sich jetzt informieren wollen würde und eine andere
Idee hat, wie man ein Problem in diesem Land lösen könnte.
Dann kann die jetzt gerade nicht Zeitung aufmachen und sagen,
mich interessiert wie, was weiß ich, das Problem der steigenden Mieten,
Das Problem, dass sehr viele Menschen bald arbeitslos werden.
Bildung, vielleicht das Problem, dass hier die Leute irgendwie nicht in dem
Maße schlauer werden, wie es eigentlich notwendig wäre in diesem Land.
Wenn man eine solche Frage stellen möchte, dann muss man da offenbar so ein
Tool vielleicht zur Hilfe nehmen.
Ja gut, ich bin gespannt.
Du weißt das alles schon.
Ich kann mich da wirklich nicht zu äußern, weil ich habe da,
ich habe keine Probleme, meine Wahlentscheidung zu fällen. Die steht fest.
Und von daher brauche ich so ein Tool.
CDU.
Wahlgeheimnis.
Zweitstimme FDP.
Wahlgeheimnis. Das sag ich jetzt nicht.
Ein parteibibeltreuer Christen ist seit jeher...
Was ist eigentlich mit den yogischen Fliegern? Die gab es doch auch mal.
Das war doch sehr unterhaltsam. Ja, hier mit irgendeiner,
ehemaligen Fernsehtorte oder so, ich weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau,
aber die war der Meinung, man müsste nur genug yogische Flieger an den Start
bringen und damit könnte man dann die Probleme der Welt eigentlich sehr effizient lösen.
Hat komischerweise keine nennenswerte Mehrheit bekommen können damals.
Also ich habe aktuell begeistert mich eine Partei, deren Wahlplakat ich gesehen
habe, das ist die Außerirdische Invasorenpartei Deutschlands.
Die tritt an für eine Unterwerfung, auf die wir wieder stolz sein können.
Und außerdem,
eine weitere Positionierung der Außerirdischen Inversorenpartei Deutschlands,
Wirtschaftsbremse Mensch überwinden, Kapitalismus in den Hyperdrive.
So und das sind ja alles erstmal das sind neue, innovative Ansätze die ich jetzt
erstmal so zur Kenntnis nehme Ist.
Das von der Bergpartei oder ist die wieder dabei?
Also das ist jetzt erstmal die Außerirdische Invasorenpartei Deutschlands.
Die haben jetzt reale Plakate gerade in der Straße?
Ja, ich weiß nicht. AIPD-Partei.de.
AIPD, achso, das ist so Künstliche Intelligenz oder was?
Außerirdische Invasorenpartei Deutschlands. Die AIPD gestaltet alternativlose
Politik für ein alternativlos besseres Morgenstopp, die Versklavung des Menschen
durch den Menschen, die Zerstörung des Planeten und die Verschwendung der kostbaren Ressourcen,
wählt die mächtige AIPD und kniet nieder.
Und die Skrack der Rachsüchtige, der Gnadenlose und der Heuchler.
Das sind die drei Kandidaten,
die von der AIPD vorgeschlagen werden. Nein zum Versager Kraut.
Ja.
Hat auch ein Parteiprogramm.
Das kannst du sogar gegen instabile Erdwährungen erhalten.
Wir müssen auch unsere Neutralität wahren. Wir können ja jetzt hier nicht einfach
irgendwelche Wahlentscheidungen vorwegnehmen. Die Leute müssen auch selber nachdenken.
Nein, ist richtig. Wir können hier nicht, wir behandeln ja auch nur innovative, neue Parteien.
Nicht irgendwelche absurden Ideen wie BSW oder so.
Aber wenn da ein neuer Stern am Parteienhimmel verglüht, dann müssen wir das doch bei uns behandeln.
Das stimmt. Ich bin da oldschool. Ich war mit den Forderungen der Bergpartei
damals schon ausreichend zufrieden.
Hat leider auch nicht zur Mehrheit gereicht.
Aber so Liebe deinen Nächsten wie dein Auto, Nägel mit Zöpfen und Naturgesetze
verschärfen, fand ich schon immer total überzeugend.
Alright. Es...
Woanders ist auch scheiße.
Tim. Ich weiß, das ist das Problem. Das ist das Problem.
Naja, mal gucken. Also vielleicht passiert ja irgendwas, wo ich meinen Optimismus
wieder gewinnen kann, aber es ist einfach gerade wirklich schwierig. Richtig schwierig.
Soweit ist es schon gekommen, dass mein Optimismus dahin geht.
Leute, da müsst ihr mal was machen.
Alright.
Aber die Goldenen Zwanziger kommen trotzdem noch. Pass auf.
Über den 20er.
Ist ja erst zur Hälfte durch.
Kommt noch, ja.
Das ist alles noch.
Du wusstest halt nicht, dass das goldene Showers von Trump sind,
von denen du da die ganze Zeit redest.
Psst. Psst. So, Leute, wir entlassen euch jetzt hier in die Woche und hoffe, ihr hattet wieder etwas,
unterhaltsamer Aufklärung von uns. No?
Minus?
Ja, ja, ja.
Du hoffst es auch. Okay.
Ja, müssen wir sonst noch irgendwas ankündigen? Mir fällt gerade nichts ein.
Ich denke nicht.
Okay, machen wir das jetzt auch nicht.
Wir haben eine Bundestagswahl angekündigt. Außerirdische Invasion wäre jetzt
ein Plottwist in der ganzen Lage, der eventuell nochmal was retten könnte.
Das stimmt, das wäre in der Tat, das käme sehr überraschend jetzt.
Das hat wirklich keiner auf seiner Bingo-Karte.
Pride!
Bei uns habt ihr es zuerst gehört.
Frage ist nur, welche Aktien hätte man jetzt kaufen müssen? Naja, okay.
Wir sagen jetzt Tschüss. Bis bald.
Bis bald. Ciao, ciao.